One of the things that's really struck
me about intellectual life is how often
we get the questions wrong and
we often get them backwards,
not just wrong,
but actually backwards.
So as a clinical psychologist,
I've often treated people
with anxiety and uh,
people wonder practically individually,
clinically,
why are people anxious?
And I think that's a
completely ridiculous question.
It,
the reasons for anxiety
are starkly self evident.
What I wonder is why aren't
people terrified out of
their skulls so badly every
second of their life that
they can't even move?
Yeah.
And you all laugh because you
understand that it's like anxiety.
That's no mystery.
It's like brief spells of calm.
That's a mystery.
Okay.
Client will come to me and say,
well,
I'm procrastinating.
Why do I procrastinate?
It's like,
no,
that's a stupid question.
It's easy just to sit
there and do nothing.
What's the mystery is why you ever get
up and do anything difficult at all?
Procrastination is the default.
And psychologists ask,
doctors ask,
well,
why do people take cocaine?
It's like,
no,
no.
It's the wrong question.
The right quest.
It is.
Why not like an addicted rat?
Don't you just take cocaine
all the time until you die.
That's the quest.
And this question about
meaning is like that too.
Is there meaning in life?
That's a stupid question.
It's,
I'm,
I'm serious about that.
That's not a question you ever
ask yourself if you're in pain,
right?
Because when you're in pain,
you know that life has a meaning.
It's the pain and you can't argue
yourself out of that meeting.
And so when we're asking
whether or not life has meaning,
that isn't what we mean.
What we mean is in the face
of life's pain and suffering,
does life have any positive meaning?
And that is not the same question.
Now,
when you leave that aside for a minute,
and I'm going to tell you a little story,
a little experiment.
I remember in 1989 when
the Berlin wall fell down,
there was a great celebration in Berlin
and the Berlin Philharmonic Orchestra
played a part in it and they came out
to a section of the wall that had been
knocked down where there was
a huge crowd and played ninth.
And I remember watching that,
the great third movement,
the triumphant third movement,
and it was so wonderful to see
everyone there and here this orchestra
playing those unbelievably remarkable
notes in triumph that this horror show had
finally come to a halt.
You can imagine someone
critically minded and rational and an
event like that standing behind you as
you're listening to the great strains
of that symphony manifest themselves,
tap you on the shoulder and say,
well,
you know
that's symphony is going to end.
What makes you think it
has any meaning at all?
It's like,
well,
how do you respond to something like that?
You say you should reconsider the
way you're looking at the world,
their buddy,
because that's just not the right answer.
It's just not the right question.
It's like the symphony has no
meaning because it ends well.
You're not paying attention
to what's going on.
If that's the way you think or
maybe you're thinking too much.
Yes,
you're thinking too much and not paying
enough attention and that is more
serious than that and this
ties in the issue of pain.
Say What does it all matter?
If in 10 billion years the earth is going
to fall into or this sun is going to
expand and consume the earth,
what difference does it make?
And I would say,
well,
is that that kind of answer you're
going to give to a child that's in pain?
That's your answer.
It's like,
Hey,
you've got the flu.
You're anxious,
you're having a nightmare.
You're in terrible pain,
but in 10 million years,
who the hell is going
to know the difference?
Yeah.
Right.
No kidding.
It's like you don't.
Yeah.
If the question is,
if that response is
observed in that situation,
then it's an absurd response.
The mere fact that you can come up with
a timeframe across which your current
activity is meaningless only means that
you're capable of playing with meanings
across timeframes.
It doesn't mean anything
at all about meaning.
As far as I can tell,
is it absolutely obligatory that
everything that's meaningful has to be
significant in some
unimaginable distant future?
Why is that the hallmark?
Why would you just say,
hey,
here's an idea.
Why don't you stop conceptualizing your
life across tight timeframes that takes
all the positive meaning out of them.
How would that be for his suggestion?
Maybe the fact that posing the question
in that way makes you feel miserable and
wretched and few tile is an indication
that there's something wrong with posing
the question in that manner.
And you might say,
well,
there's nothing wrong
with posing questions.
And I would say,
well that brings us back to
the child in pain problem.
Sometimes there is a problem with posing
questions in a certain way and what
difference is it gonna make in 10
million years is not a sufficient
response to someone who's suffering.
And then you might say,
well,
we could,
we could expand that idea.
Even we could take play
with that idea of suffering.
We could say,
well,
maybe it's a child in Auschwitz,
you know,
and this suffering isn't merely
a consequence of an illness.
Not that that's trivial,
but the suffering is the
consequence of conscious malevolent.
How about that?
And the purpose of the malevolence
is just to make things worse.
And,
and to top it all off because
malevolence is a form of art.
It's not only to make things worse,
it's to make things worse in the
worst possible imaginable way,
which is basically to amplify this
suffering of someone maximumly innocent in
the most pointless way possible.
Well,
what,
what's your answer to that?
It's like
10 million years.
What difference is it going to make?
Life is fundamentally meaningless.
It's like what kind of answers that
it's an answer that shows that the
framework within which that question is
generated is invalid.
That's what kind of answer it is.
All right.
I realized a while back that I had
gone through a process when I was in my
twenties.
It was akin to something Descartes did.
I'm not trying to compare
myself to Descartes.
Um,
but he was,
he was trying to look for something that
he couldn't doubt and the consequence
of his search was,
I think therefore I am,
which I don't think is exactly a good
translation of what Descartes meant.
I think he meant something more like
I can't dispute the reality of my own
consciousness.
Something like that.
And that's good.
That isn't where I got
to in my contemplations.
I was looking for something that I
regarded as in controvertible and I was
fortunate at that time because I
was reading Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn,
Solzhenitsyn Road,
the Gulag archipelago
among many other things.
The Gulag archipelago is a description
of the absolute catastrophes of the
Soviet state and the entanglement of
the individual psyches of the Soviet
citizens in that catastrophe descent into
deceit and cruelty to seat resentment
and cruelty when Solzhenitsyn,
the Gulag archipelago that he thought
the Nuremberg trials were the most
important event of the 20th century.
And the reason he said that
was because the Nuremberg
judgment for better or worse,
was that there were some acts that were
so viciously brutal that there was no
excuse whatsoever for engaging in them,
no matter who you were or what your
culture was or what your rationale was.
And so for,
for soldier,
an incident,
the Nuremberg trials established what
you might describe as the transcendent
reality of evil.
And that's an unbelievably useful thing.
It's akin to this idea of
suffering in my estimation because,
well,
it's the child in there
in Auschwitz problem that
you need an answer
to the problem posed by
the suffering of innocence
as a consequence of malevolent.
You say that's,
that's a,
that's evil.
The conscious exaggeration of unnecessary
suffering and that gives you a vantage
point that's wrong.
Whatever it is that is,
that's wrong.
Well then you have
a place to stand.
You can say,
oh,
okay,
now I know that there's something that's
wrong and now non trivial way in a way
that tech can't be just dispensed with,
with rational objections
that emerge as a consequence of
contemplation of the boundedness of life.
Those answers aren't serious
enough to address the issue.
Well.
So I thought,
okay,
well I found something that I can
grip onto or stand on without dispute.
There are acts that are unquestionably
evil and that means that there are acts
that are unquestionably good.
Now,
it doesn't mean that
we know what they are,
right?
Because just because you
know one pole of something,
it doesn't necessarily mean you know.
The other.
I could say that whatever leads us as
far as way as we can possibly get from
Auschwitz,
that's good.
Well
are being turned to puzzle out
what that might be for 25 years.
To outline it in a practical manner,
I suppose in an abstract manner,
to understand if there's a root,
a mode of being,
let's say that takes us
away from undue suffering,
but more than that takes us away from
undue suffering multiplied by malevolence.
He said it's a fundamental
existential problem of life.
We all suffer.
That's the meaning of life.
The suffering is exacerbated by the
malevolence in our hearts and the
malevolence in the hearts of all of us
and the paramount issue that
faces us is what to do about that,
and the answer is I think
live a life that manifests itself as
meaningful because it seems to me that the
meaning isn't a rational phenomena.
It's not something that you create.
This is where Nietzsche,
I think got it wrong.
He believed that as a consequence
of the death of God we had,
we would have to create our own values.
We would have to become gods ourselves,
so to speak.
Okay.
But I don't think that Nisha was right
because I don't think that we can create
our own values.
I think that we have to discover them.
And I think that what we discover,
our eternal values,
and I think that the eternal values
that are discoverable are precisely the
values that lead us away from
the pathway to perdition.
It was characterized by
places such as Auschwitz.
And I also think that
we all know this now.
It's not that we can't question
it because we can question it,
but the questioning is in some sense,
beside the point,
like the person objecting to the Grand
Juror grandier of Beethoven's ninth by
pointing out that it's going to end.
The questioning is beside the point.
It's missing the point.
I've studied a variety
of great psychologists,
John Piaget and Carl Young and,
and Freud and Carl Rogers,
many of the great 20th century clinicians.
And,
and my stance is that along with
the biologists and the evolutionary
psychologists that were,
we're starting to map out the pathway
that might be the opposite of the
catastrophic motive being that leads
us into pits of hell like Auschwitz.
And that there's something
genuinely real about it.
Like seriously,
real,
metaphorically real,
and literally real,
both at the same time that the instinct
to meaning that you experience,
for example,
when you listen to something great,
that,
that experience of meaning that
overcomes you isn't some EPR phenomena.
It's not something,
some mirror reflection of
some more fundamental process,
but that which is more
fundamental than anything else
say,
well,
you can't deny that pain is real and
suffering is real and you can't deny that
suffering induced by malevolence is
the worst of all possible sufferings.
Those are all undeniable
as far as I'm concerned.
Those are all meanings of life and the
real enough so that if you encounter
them,
like if you encounter true malevolence,
the probability that you'll walk
away from it and escape this is very,
very low.
It will damage you psychophysiological
and you might never recover.
And that's real enough for me.
Well,
it is.
The path away from that real
is the path that transcends that real.
Maybe it's more real.
That's what I've come to believe as
pessimistic as I am about the nature of
humanity,
myself included,
as,
as real as I believe
suffering and evil to be.
It appears to me that the mode of
being that leads you away from that,
that enables you to bear the suffering
with nobility and to be useful to others
who are in pain and to constrain the
malevolence in your own heart and around
you.
That that mode of being is more powerful
than that which it is set against.
And not only that,
I think that we experienced this.
I think we experienced it.
We just don't notice.
Maybe because we're too busy thinking
because noticing and thinking aren't the
same thing we see in our own lives
when we're engaged in something deeply
meaningful.
Music is the best pathway to that.
I think it's the most,
it's the most rapid and
indisputable pathway to that.
Everyone,
virtually everyone loves music
and music speaks of meaning.
It doesn't directly and it shows you
what life would be like if it was ordered
and harmonious and you were
dancing along with it properly.
It gives you an intimation
of psychological integrity,
but you watched your lives day to day,
week to week,
month to month.
You'll notice that there are times when
you're so deeply engaged in what you're
doing.
What you're doing is so meaningful in the
kind of meaning that announces itself,
not the kind that you're creating,
that life is so meaningful.
You think
this is worth the suffering.
Let me think.
Well that's meaning,
right?
Meaning is what makes
the suffering worthwhile.
Is that real?
It's not something you think up.
It's something that you
discover and you can watch.
You could see day to day,
minute to minute,
hour to hour,
week to week.
You can see when you're
conducting yourself or being
conducted in a manner that
allows that meaning to reveal
itself in a way that in the moment,
even if you don't notice
the conditions of your life,
justify themselves and,
and that's really saying something because
pain and suffering and malevolence or
real and for something to justify that
it's really something for something to
justify that.
But will you find that you find it in art,
you find it in literature,
you find it in the relationships
you have with others.
If those relationships are
founded on trust and truth,
you find it in what you say and do.
If what you say and do
comes from the heart,
you can experience that.
The price of experiencing it,
I would say is two fold.
You have to take responsibility for being,
you have to do that voluntarily and
that means that you have to take
responsibility for the suffering of being
an excepted and work to ameliorate it.
And you have to do that voluntarily.
And that's a barrier,
I think very frequently
that arguments like,
well,
what difference is it going to make 10
million years in the future aren't hyper
rational objections to the
nature of being itself,
but hyper rationalistic
excuses for failing to bear
the responsibility of living
properly,
moment to moment,
and our tower there.
Okay,
say you have a child who's sick,
maybe one who's been hurt.
You say,
well,
what do you say or do in the face of that?
Well,
you say,
Hey kid,
I'm here with you.
I'm here beside you.
Matters what's happening to you and
where to do everything we possibly can to
get through this together.
And if you're lucky,
you get a hug.
And as a consequence
of that and you think,
if you don't think that's meaningful,
man,
there's something wrong
with your soul and answer.
What the hell difference is it
gonna make in 10 million years?
That's the devil himself speaking.
Oh,
that's good enough.